hey everyone are you also fascinated by
the world of cyber security well ethical
hacking and penetration testing are two
of the most exciting in-demand jobs of
2023. with an average salary of 145 000
in the United States well did you know
that according to a study by cyber
security Ventures employment in these
fields is expected to increase by 15
between 2020 and 2028. that's over 5
million job openings by 2026 at an
incredible annual growth rate of 35
companies like IBM Accenture and
Deloitte are hiring ethical hackers and
penetration testers with salary reaching
as high as 19 lakh rupees in India the
demand for skilled Professionals in the
field is so high that a survey conducted
by the international EC Council found
that 8 out of 10 cyber security
positions go unfilled so are you ready
to join the fight against cyber crime
and become a highly sought after ethical
hacker or penetration tester well a
credited courses can help you achieve
your goals and land your dream job so
you are one of them who wants to take
your career to the next level simply
learns professional certificate program
in ethical hacking and penetration
testing in collaboration with IIT kanpur
will boost your career as a cyber
security expert now this professional
certification program covers ethical
hacking in cyber security this course
covers the concepts consequences the
instinctions and limitations of ethical
hacking next up is vulnerability
assessment in cyber security in this
course you will cover vulnerability
assessment techniques like scanning
checking configuration and architecture
correlation and mapping of attacks to
evaluate the efficacy of Defense
in-depth architecture following that its
penetration technique in cyber security
in this scope you will learn the
advanced skills required to identify and
Patch security gaps across ID system you
will work on Kali Linux for advanced
penetration testing and auditing along
with scanning techniques like TCP syn
and TCP Windows scan and other network
working scanning tools like like nmap
and HP ing next we have a cyber security
Capstone project that will give you an
opportunity to implement the skills
covered throughout this program through
dedicated mentoring sessions you will
learn how to solve real world industry
align caps on problems along with that
topics like cryptography Concepts
anonymity concept ideas firewalls and
honey pots and web app threads will also
be covered in this course so what else
can you expect from this program this
program includes program completion
certificate from IIT kanpur one of the
India's top technical institutes and
simply learn master classes from IIT
kanpur faculty and eight into higher
interaction in live online classes by
industry experts with 24 into 7 learning
support you will also get hands-on
experience with Capstone projects like
gain access to a victim's machine vapt
on a bank application and vulnerability
assessment and exploitation on industry
relevant use cases you will also get
seamless access to integrated Labs on
simply LMS for developing industrial
line projects and build skills like
ethical hacking cryptography Concepts
vulnerability assessment penetration
testing web app threats exploiting and
gaining access and anonymity concept and
also hands-on experience on tools like
Kali Linux burp suit Google doc
Wireshark to become job ready and
Advance your career also of the
successful completion of this PCP in
ethical hacking and penetration testing
course you will be eligible for simply
Loans job assist and career service like
IM jobs Pro membership of six months for
free you will also get resume building
assistant to create a powerful resume
interview preparation to help you land
your dream Job and Career Mentoring to
help you achieve your career goals by
getting noticed by top hiring companies
like American Express Microsoft Google
IBM and Netflix this PCP and ethical
hacking and penetration testing in
collaboration with IIT kanpur provides
you with the skills necessary to
leverage offensive cyber security to
strengthen the stability and security of
ID systems you will benefit from and be
better able to master the highly sought
after cyber security capabilities owing
to the comprehensive curriculum of this
program simply learn also offers
financial aid in terms of Emi so what
are you waiting for don't miss out on
this chance to take your career to the
next level enroll in a PCP and ethical
hacking and penetration testing in
collaboration with IIT Khan for today
and start your journey to become a cyber
security expert the link is added in the
description box and comment section
below
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign